OK, I want to talk now about this issue of
churches at the top of the show.
I talk to you about how the Corona virus pandemic
in the United.
Gates is now a culture war.
It's not really a fight for the best ideas
about how to deal with the virus while taking
care of the economy.
That would be the right thing to do.
It's merely a culture war.
Now, thanks to the Trump administration, thanks
to Trump's fixation on opening churches and
opening them right away, we also now have
to talk a little bit more specifically about
the houses of worship component.
But I just want to recontextualize the church's
thing is one piece of the broader culture
war that Corona virus is now about.
It's not about public health.
Let's talk about the legal element of the
church openings, Donald Trump said late last
week.
Governors must, must, must at his direction,
designate houses of worship as essential organizations
so that they are allowed to reopen in places
where they have been closed.
And Donald Trump even said if governors don't
determine that churches are essential, I will
override governors and make sure that churches
are deemed essential.
Let's look at this.
This is from a press briefing late last week
from Baled without taking any questions.
After saying the following.
I know them well.
They love their congregations.
They love their people.
They don't want anything bad to happen to
them or to anybody else.
The governors need to do the right thing and
allow these very important, essential places
of faith to open right now for this weekend
if they don't do it.
I will override the governors in America.
We need more prayer, not less.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Mr. President.
So there are multiple layers to this.
First is the question.
Are houses of worship really essential?
OK, now I'm going to be I'm going to be exceedingly
fair on this issue.
Houses of worship are not essential to the
economy.
Houses of worship are not essential to public
health.
And they are not essential to life.
You don't need churches like you need a grocery
store because without food, you die.
But I understand culturally that churches
are seen as essential by religious folks.
I don't see it that way, but I know many people
do.
That's why this is the perfect issue for Trump
to focus on in order to wage Corona virus
as a culture war.
It's perspective if you think that the most
important thing for humanity is making sure
that you are praying in the right place and
that your religion is what's holding the society
together, you're going to be difficult to
convince that churches aren't essential.
And that's why this is the perfect way for
Trump to wage Corona virus as a culture war.
Then we have the public health component.
If restaurants can't yet be open to in, how
do you justify churches being open?
You can dine in in a restaurant much more
safely and in much less time than you can
go to a church on the average.
You can social distance theoretically in a
restaurant, and you can social distance theoretically
in a church, but you can get in and out of
a restaurant very quickly compared to how
long people tend to be in churches, restaurants
at full capacity, sometimes only accommodate
15, 20 or 25 people.
Small restaurants.
I'm talking about churches are almost always
at least 50 people, sometimes hundreds, sometimes
thousands, sometimes tens of thousands at
these megachurches.
We know of churches being super spreaders
where they have one service and a ton of people
end up infected because of one person.
So from a public health perspective, there
is no way that you can defend churches being
open when restaurants are still closed for
dining.
Lastly, and maybe most importantly, let's
focus on the legal.
Trump says he will override governors.
He can't do it.
He does not have that authority.
It doesn't actually matter, by the way, that
he can't do it.
And I mean, I tell you why in a second.
But from a legal perspective, Trump often
talks about federalism.
Federalism just means a system with a federal
government and also subsequent either state
or provincial government.
That's all that means state or provincial
governments in the United States.
It is outlined in the 10th Amendment.
And the 10th Amendment lays out the default
power dynamics between state and federal government,
where it says, quote, The powers not delegated
to the United States by the Constitution nor
prohibited by it to the states are reserved
to the states, respectively, or to the people.
So, in other words, if there is some action
or power that the Constitution or Bill of
Rights don't specifically say the federal
government has power over this and the Constitution
and Bill of Rights don't ban states from having
power over that.
The default is states decide about that issue.
Designation of churches as essential or nonessential
is not a power given to the federal government
and it is not a power from which states are
restricted.
Thus, federalism and the 10th Amendment confirm
that Trump has no authority whatsoever.
Full stop, black and white.
Period.
To determine what types of entities are essential
from the perspective of states.
That is really the the analysis that's required.
We don't need to go further now to finish
this up.
It doesn't actually matter politically that
Trump has no authority to force governors
to say churches are essential because by merely
saying this, Donald Trump has already virtue
signaled he has called for churches to be
designated as essential.
He has claimed that we hope he will override
governors.
That's really all that matters.
If you are a trampas from a section of the
religious Trump voters, you don't care that
he won't actually override governors.
You don't care that he can't override governors.
He has said what he needed to say.
He says he wants to override governors and
that he believes churches should open right
away.
That's it.
It's Virtu cygwin signaling at its worst.
The right is quick to criticize virtue signaling
when they see it from the left.
This is absolutely the worst of the worst
virtue.
Signaling, signaling.
Lastly, what Trump could do or what he could
try is to withhold money from states if they
don't do what he wants.
It would be sick.
It would be immoral.
I don't know whether it would be legal, but
Trump has already threatened Michigan and
Nevada about withholding money if they do
vote by mail.
That he could absolutely threaten.
Whether he would do it, whether he could do
it is a further question to which we don't
have an answer right now.
We're going to continue covering this story
on the show's Instagram at David Pakman show.
Also, I am having a rabbit fiasco in my backyard.
I'm going to talk about it on today's bonus
show.
But you can also follow the craziness on my
personal Instagram at David Pakman.
Plus on my personal Instagram, the most popular
post I've ever made to Instagram.
It's me holding a copy over the weekend, just
me holding a puppy.
Nothing else.
And it is exploding on my Instagram.
Follow me at David go